so during an election one of the most  difficult choices we have to make is do  we vote for a candidate are we voting  against a candidate obviously the  hardcore Democrats are voting for  Warnock and the hardcore Republicans are  voting for Walker but the people who are  kind of in the middle are on the fence  are trying to decide are they voting for  Warnock and what he stands for are they  voting against Walker and all the  mistakes he made in his campaign in my  hope is that for all the people out  there the politicians the entrepreneurs  who have a message of optimism and  kindness and believe that you're trying  to spread that you stand up for your  mission that people know who you are  that you are loud and you're trying to  spread more positivity loudly and use  your voice so people can recognize you  and can say what your mission is all  about so that if you win it's not  because people are just voting against  the other guy they're voting for you